number 31 is a mercedes prime but we're
not going to talk about why it's my
saying today we're going to look at why
it's a truly lucky number i'm going to
start off with a whole bunch of numbers
to begin with i've listed the numbers
one just up to 58. okay now i'm going to
use an algorithm that sieves out my
numbers to ensure that i only get lucky
numbers
so to begin with i'm going to eliminate
every other number from my list so i
start with number one and we're going to
get rid of every other one from there on
so two's gone
four's gone so all of my even numbers
you can see
are going these are unlucky in terms of
my mathematical algorithm
now i'm going to start eliminating more
numbers by going on to the next step of
my algorithm
now a second iteration so i look at the
second number in the terms that i've got
left so my second number is 3
because it's three i'm now going to
start eliminating every third number
so that's my first number one
three is my second number five will be
the third number so we get rid of five
one two three let me get rid of 11.
okay so at the moment one and three are
both safe they're lucky numbers
we carry on with the algorithm the next
number i need to look at is number seven
so now number seven tells me how many
numbers i need to get rid of eliminate i
eliminate every seventh number
so we start from the beginning one two
three four
five six
seven
one two three four
five six seven we move on to our next
number nine
so i now start eliminating every ninth
number
so our first lots of looking numbers are
7 9 13. i'm looking for some
15 21 25 and 31 our special number
tell me something else about 31 can you
i can 31 is a pentagonal number do you
know what that means 5 26 27 28 29 30
31.
so on the fourth iteration we get our
pentagonal number 31. i've realized why
your pentagon's so bad it's because i'm
making you draw it yeah from my
perspective it looks kind of okay
if i slightly turn this board around
is it looking any better yeah
i can see why you've done it now
oh
the beauty of maths